the year 2021 the problem Sri Lanka's
Farms aren't organic the solution an
immediate Nationwide ban on synthetic
fertilizer and pesticides which
coincidentally Sav Sri Lanka $400
million in annual subsidy costs while
they wrestle with a deep financial
crisis oh right maybe that was the real
problem sounds like a great idea with
the best of intentions what could
possibly go wrong turns out synthetic
fertilizer and pesticides actually work
6 months after the presidential decree
Sri Lanka's biggest export tea was down
18% and rights production plunged 20%
forcing the once proudly self-sufficient
country to import rice at a cost of $450
million due to public backlash the
government was forced to reverse their
ban and pay out hundreds of millions to
compensate Farmers deepening the
country's economic crisis and Fanning
protests that led to the president's
resignation and temporary exile rice NOA